hallo deutsch schule wörter mit den
umlauten ä
der käse der käse ein toast mit käse ein
toast mit käse der käse tost der käse
tost zum frühstück esse ich einen käse
tost das olivenöl das olivenöl das
olivenöl für den salat das olivenöl für
den salat
das olivenöl ist sehr gesund
ich benutze das olivenöl zum kochen
benutzt du auch das olivenöl zum kochen
der baum die bäume der baum die bäume
die bäume sind grün die bäume sind grün
im wald gibt es viele bäume im wald gibt
es viele bäume die bäume produzieren
sauerstoff die bäume produzieren
sauerstoff die möwe die möwe
die möwe liebt den strand die möwe liebt
den strand am strand gibt es viele möwen
am strand gibt es viele möwen die möwe
fliegt gerne über das meer die möwe
fliegt gerne über das meer die nuss die
nüsse die nuss die nüsse die erdnüsse
die erdnüsse die weine die weine die
kokosnüsse die kokosnüsse das
eichhörnchen liebt müsse das
eichhörnchen liebt nüsse
liebst du auch nüsse der apfel die äpfel
der apfel die äpfel die äpfel sind rot
die äpfel sind rot die äpfel sind sehr
gesund
die äpfel sind sehr gesund
die äpfel hängen an dem apfelbaum die
äpfel hängen an dem apfelbaum die
bäckerei die bäckerei der bäcker
arbeitet in der bäckerei der bäcker
backt eine torte der bäcker backt eine
torte
ich hätte gerne ein stück käsetorte
bitte ich hätte gerne ein stück
käsetorte bitte ägypten ägypten in
ägypten gibt es pyramiden in ägypten
gibt es pyramiden die pyramide die
pyramide
köln köln köln ist eine stadt in
deutschland
köln ist eine stadt in deutschland in
köln steht der berühmte kölner dom in
köln steht der berühmte kölner dom
der löffel der löffel der löffel zum
kochen ist der kochlöffel der löffel zum
kochen ist der kochlöffel der kochlöffel
der kochlöffel der koch kocht mit dem
kochlöffel der koch kocht mit dem
kochlöffel der schlüssel der schlüssel
der schlüssel für die tür ist der
türschlüssel der schlüssel für die tür
ist der türschlüssel der türschlüssel
der türschlüssel
ich schließe die tür mit dem
türschlüssel auf ich schließe die tür
mit dem türschlüssel auf das büro das
büro das bürogebäude das bürogebäude
ich arbeite im büro ich arbeite im büro
die süßigkeiten die süßigkeiten viele
leckere süßigkeiten viele leckere
süßigkeiten im supermarkt gibt es viele
leckere süßigkeiten im supermarkt gibt
es viele leckere süßigkeiten die wüste
die wüste die sahara ist eine wüste die
sahara ist eine wüste in der wüste gibt
es kamele in der wüste gibt es kamele
der könig der könig der könig trägt eine
krone der könig trägt eine krone die
krone
die krone der föhn der füllen
der föhn sind die haare trocken
der film fängt die haare trocken
ich fühle mir mit dem föhn die haare
trocken
ich fühle mir mit dem füllen die haare
die möhre die möhre die möhre heißt auch
karotte die möhre heißt auch karotte die
karotte die karotte möhren sind gut für
die augen möhren sind gut für die augen
ist du auch gerne möhren der größe der
rüssel der elefant hat einen rüssel der
elefant hat einen rüssel der elefanten
nutzt den rüssel zum essen der elefant
benutzt den rüssel zum essen süden süden
norden osten süden
westen norden osten süden westen
spanien ist im süden von europa spanien
ist im süden von europa die bücher die
bücher
die bücher stehen in einem regal
die bücher stehen in einem regal das
bücherregal das bücherregal
ich lerne deutsch mit den deutsch
büchern
büchern wie lernst du deutsch
der zahn die zähne der zahn die zähne
die zähne putzen mit der zahnbürste die
zähne putzen mit der zahnbürste die
zahnbürste die zahnbürste ich putze mir
die zähne mit der zahnbürste
ich putze mir die zähne mit der
zahnbürste das gemüse das gemüse im
supermarkt gibt es frisches gemüse im
supermarkt gibt es frisches gemüse
broccoli paprika und mais sind
gemüsesorten broccoli paprika und mais
sind gemüsesorten die rüstung die
rüstung der ritter trägt
eine rüstung der ritter trägt eine
rüstung die ritterrüstung die
ritterrüstung die ritterrüstung schützt
den ritter die ritterrüstung schützt den
ritter das känguru das känguru das
känguru das känguru hüpft in australien
gibt es viele kängurus in australien
gibt es viele kängurus hast du schon mal
ein echtes känguru gesehen abonniere den
kanal der halo deutsch schule und
aktiviere das kleine glöckchen wenn dir
das video gefallen hat dann gib uns
jetzt ein daumen nach oben und in dieser
playlist findest du weitere videos zum
deutschlernen klicke jetzt auf diese
playlist